اكيد في اخر وداع لسياسه صفر كوبيد وضعت
الصين حدا
لثلاث سنوات من العزله بسبب الوباء فرفعت
لزميل المسافرين القادمين من الخارج
واعادت فتح الحدود رسميا قرار المفاجاه
اتخذته الصين في وقت تواجه فيه البلاد
موجه وبئيه جديده سريعه لانتشار وربما
الاسوء في بعض المناطق وهذه المفارقه التي
رايناها في الصوره الاخيره بفرحه السفر
للصينيين بلا قيود وهذه الصوره لتكدس
المصابين بكرونا في المستشفيات وهو ما اثر
مخاوف عالميه سيما في ظل اجراءات
الاحترازيه اتخذتها عده دول بفرض قيود على
القادمين من الصين وفور القرار بفتح
الحدود مباشره الصينيين بالعبور بينهم
كونج والبر الرئيسيه للصين بعد اعلان رفع
قيود السفر كما تم السماحه نحو 60,000 شخص
بالسفر يوميا بين هونغ كونغ والبر الرئيسي
للصين فيما ينوي اكثر من 400,000 شخص في
السفر الى الشمال خلال الاسابيع الثمانيه
المقبله وتطالب السلطات المسافرين بتقديم
الدليل على اجراء اختبار حديث لكنه تكون
نتيجه سلبيه